pour autant que nos connaissances nous
permettent de l'affirmer la terre notre
planète est un cas unique dans l'univers
même dans ces contrées plus arides on
découvre la vie
autour de l'équateur où la chaleur et
d'humidité
ces éléments vitaux sont
particulièrement dense on trouve de
grandes forêts les plantes et les
animaux y prolifèrent au point que nous
n'avons pu encore en identifier toutes
les espèces
ici les animaux et les plantes les
insectes et des oiseaux
l'homme enfin cohabitent dans des
communautés inquiets complexe
dépendantes les unes des autres
les deux tiers de cette planète unique
sont recouvert par l'eau ou la vie a
pris naissance
à partir des océans la vie s'est
répandue jusqu'au sommet des plus hautes
montagnes plantes et animaux se sont
adaptés aux différents milieux
ils ont évolué au gré des
transformations de la terre elle-même la
fraie son chemin de manière étonnante
directement à travers la chaîne de
montagne la plus haute du monde
l'himalaya à l'est l'anapurna plus de
8000 mètres d'altitude à l'ouest encore
plus haut le dhaulagiri leur sommet ne
sont distants que de 35 km et je me
trouve à leurs pieds
6000 mètres plus bas cela signifie que
cette vallée est la plus profonde du
monde halal ticket de nous ne trouvons
environ 2000 mètres il fait suffisamment
chaud pour que la vie animale et
végétale soit riche et abondante sur les
deux versants de la vallée ces fleurs
peuvent vous paraître familière on en
trouve en effet de robert desjardins un
peu partout dans le monde mais ici elles
sont sauvages et elle pousse sur leur
lieu d'origine
ce sont des rhododendrons l'une des 500
espèces de l'himalaya des singes de la
mesure gris trouve assis nourrir et cela
nous rappelle que les chaudes plaines du
sud népal et les tropiques ne sont pas
loin
ici j'ai aussi plusieurs espèces de
faisans parmi les plus beaux oiseaux
d'asie le fait que cette vallée sur la
plus profonde du monde permet d'y passer
en quelques jours d'un site tropicale à
la base à des paysages polaires au
sommet et d'observer au fil de la
promenade
comment plantes et animaux s'adaptent
parfaitement à ces conditions de vie
changeantes en altitude plus de
rhododendrons mais dans la moiteur
chaudes de l'été on peut découvrir
encore sur la mousse des troncs des
orchidées et sur le sol de fleurs
apparaissent en bouquet serré pour se
protéger mutuellement des pinocchio le
petit panda de l'himalaya de la taille
ne renard est parfaitement protégée du
froid par son épaisse fourrure et par le
fait que des poils me pose sous la
plante des pieds gardant ceci au chaud
et l'empêchant aussi de glisser sur la
glace
au sol à peine plus grand que le panda a
répliqué me des habitants de la forêt
himalayenne le chevreau impôts retenus
sq dans cet enchevêtrement d'arbres des
bois lui aurait été un handicap
considérable le chevrote importe muscles
ne les a donc pas développé pour
attaquer le mal dispose de défense
longue de 7 à 8 cm
dès qu'un animal meurt quels qu'en
soient la taille arrivent les vautours
ceux ci sont des vautours fauves est
très semblable à ceux qui tournoient
dans le ciel des villages d'indiens plus
barque au pied des collines
on en trouve couramment jusqu'à 2500 m
ici nous sommes à 3000 m la forêt
s'éclaircit en été à cette altitude
les pluies sont rares et en hiver il
fait extrêmement froid des conditions
qui ne conviennent qu aux seuls
conifères malgré l'altitude le cours de
gamme dac est très large
bizarrement la rivière ne sert porte pas
au pied des flancs des montagnes géante
mais coupe tout droit à travers elle il
ya longtemps que les populations qui
vivent au pied des collines exploite
cette extraordinaire couloir qu'il est
même directement à travers l'himalaya
durant tout l'été et des caravanes de
mule remonte laval est chargé d'orge et
de sarrasin qu'elle croque avec l'équipe
étape en échange de l'année de celle là
plus haut encore ne subsiste que de
petits arbustes et quelques touffes
d'herbes desséché qui suffisait en moins
à nourrir le tard un curieux ruminants
qui tient à la fois de la fièvre et du
mouton autres créatures qui piquent de
la montagne le show car avec john
il s'élève jusqu'à la hauteur des pics
enneigés en utilisant les courants
ascendants
seul fleuriste encore à cette altitude
quelques plantes rassemblés en coussin à
proximité des sommets ne subsiste enfin
que les lichens auquel le froid
n'autorise que quelques jours de
croissance par an pourtant des hommes
vis pour les aider à labourer leurs
champs il utilise le yat qui avait
autrefois en liberté dans les plaines du
tibre et qu'ils ont domestiqué
c'est le seul grand mammifère qu'ils
livrent en permanence à ses auteurs
ces populations les bottières et les
repas sont parfaitement adaptés à la vie
en haute altitude leur sang tout
particulièrement riche en globules
rouges véhicule ainsi plus d'oxygène que
celui des habitants de la plaine ainsi
donc une fois de plus l'environnement a
façonné modifiez transformez les espèces
vivantes qu'elle soit humaine ou animale
mais toutes ces adaptations biologiques
sont récentes en montagne ces neiges
éternelles sont loin de remonter à la
nuit des temps
elles sont plus jeunes que les plaines
de l'est au sud et que le plateau du
tibet au nord est se sont dressés à
leurs auteurs actuels il y environ 65
millions d'années
réagissant du fond de la mer alors
qu'est ce qui nous permet cette
affirmation
on peut en trouver la preuve à cet
endroit même
ces pentes sont recouvertes de curieux
fragments comme celui ci il s'agit à
l'évidence d'un coquillage pétrifié daf
aussi bien qu'il n'existe plus
aujourd'hui de mollusques comme celui ci
n'a qu il en existe d'autres
suffisamment similaires pour qu'on
puisse affirmer que cet ancêtre vivait
lui aussi dans le fait d'ailleurs en
analysant la roche dans laquelle il
pétrifiée nous voyons qu'elle était à
l'origine de la boue marin
pourtant je suis aussi loin la mer qu'il
est possible de l'être au milieu de
l'asie à des milliers de kilomètres de
la mer la plus proche mais également à
quelque 3200 mètres au dessus de son
niveau
alors quelle force ont pu élever le lit
de la mer à cette hauteur nous savons
maintenant que ses forces sont en action
nous savons que ces montagnes continue
de grandir et que les continents sont
toujours en phase de création
je suis ici en islande
cette fantastique fontaine de feu qui
s'élèvent à 60 mètres et composé de
roches en fusion
tout autour tombe de la sandrine il y à
des courants d'air suffocant des gaz
toxiques et il fait tellement chaud que
je ne peux m'en approcher davantage des
régions comme celle ci ont de toute
éternité connu une intense activité
volcanique
à la chaussée des géants en irlande il y
à 50 millions d'années après avoir forcé
leur chemin à travers les corses
terrestre les l'âge se sont contractés
en d'étranges colonnes de basalte
prismatique
bien loin de là aux hébrides on retrouve
le même type de colonnes mais mesurant 6
mètres de haut est recouverte ici d'une
couche de l'avs non-encore airaudo
ces volcans d'islande proviennent
d'immenses fissures qui s'ouvre
régulièrement sur toute la largeur de
lille
il s'agit en fait de l'extrémité
septentrionale d'une vaste chaîne de
montagne ou dorsales océaniques de
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres
creuset d'une profonde fosse qui
parcourt le globe du nord au sud
la plus grande partie de cette faille
recouverte de stries de lave et sous
marines
c'est la raison pour laquelle son
existence n'a été découverte qu'au début
de ce siècle
partant de l'islande au bord du cercle
arctique
elle traverse l'océan à distance égale
de l'europe et de l'afrique à l'est des
amériques à l'ouest à certains endroits
il surnage pour créer des îles
volcaniques les açores le cap vert l'île
de l'ascension sainte hélène tristan da
cunha le basalte ne feront pas seulement
les dorsales océaniques il déborde sur
le fond de la mer par analyse chimique
on a constaté que la lave la plus
éloignée du centre du sillon est la plus
ancienne
le magma en fusion jaillissant de la
faille se solidifie ensuite en basalte
de chaque côté de celle ci basalte qui
est repoussé par de nouvelle remontée du
magma
si bien que le fond des océans est en
continuelle expansion
on ne connaît pas encore toutes les
forces qui engendre ce processus mais il
semble qu'à une distance de 80 à 100
kilomètres en dessous de la surface
terrestre
la chaleur est telle que la roche en
fusion et parcourue par des courants qui
la font jaillir à travers la faille et
s'écoulent et ensuite de chaque côté du
sillon en entraînant avec elles les
grandes plaques de l'écorcé terrestre
c'est ce mouvement qui a entraîné la
séparation de l'afrique et de l'amérique
du sud et la création de l'océan
atlantique des événements similaires se
sont produits dans le pacifique
le grand plateau qui forment la partie
est du fond de l'océan est en mouvement
en direction de la côte ouest de
l'amérique mais à l'endroit où il
rencontre le continent poussé par un
courant descendant il plonge sous la
croûte terrestre provoquant une profonde
tranchée dans le fond de l'océan
il y entraîne les sédiments accumulés
sur le fond en même temps que de l'eau
mélanger au magma ces nouveaux
ingrédients constituent une mixture
nouvelle enrichi en gaz dissous et en
vapeur
en s'échappant vers la surface à travers
les failles du sol se refroidit se
solidifie obstrue de cheminée l'accès
l'effet est comparable au blocage de la
soupape d'une cocotte-minute
le mont sainte hélène sur la côte
pacifique de l'amérique du nord
le 10 mai 1981 une éruption au souffle
500 fois plus puissant que celui de la
bombe d'hiroshima éjecte plus d'un kilo
mètres cubes de roche à peu près un
siècle plus tôt en 1883 de l'autre côté
du pacifique avait lieu une autre
éruption spectaculaire sur la petite île
de krakatoa entre java et sumatra
cette éruption qui tannait ce que
provoque un raz-de-marée développant des
vagues de plus de 30 mètres de haut
les trois-quarts de l'île disparurent
tandis que deux petits îlots proches qui
est entièrement recouvert de cendre 44
ans plus tard un autre cratère jaillit
de la mer anac krakatoa l'enfant de
tracas tôt il connaît des éruptions
sporadiques mais il est possible de
parcourir ses bords du volcan
jaillissent en permanence des vapeurs et
des gaz sulfureux qui en se condensant
teigne laroche en jaune les volcans mais
demeure pas éternellement actifs à terme
des modifications se produisent sous la
croûte terrestre les foyers de chaleur
intense se déplace si de l'eau filtre en
surface peut se créer une source
thermale un geyser telle que celle du
parc de yellowstone en amérique du nord
l'eau qui jaillit de septfontaines
naturel est d'une limpidité cristalline
et chimiquement riche mais tellement
chaude qu aucune créature ne peut vivre
par contre dès qu elles s'écoulent en
surface et commence à refroidir on y
observe un foisonnement de colonies
bactériennes ainsi que la formation de
tapis d'algues et sur lesquelles
apparaissent rapidement des insectes qui
viennent ici alimenter ici à coupler ce
sont des efi grid et fidra sorte de
mouche d'une famille dont la
caractéristique est que la larve se
développent dans des milieux aussi
étrange que le pétrole ou le formol
les oeufs sont déposés à même le tapis
show constitué par les algues chacun
d'eux possède allons filaments blancs
comme irène ils sont loin d'être en
sécurité ils sont convoitées par les
mythes qui escaladent les algues par des
araignées qui elle aussi rôde autour de
la colonie par d'autres mouche enfin
plus grande que les epide rider qui elle
aussi se nourrissent volontiers de
larmes
ainsi le tapis d'algues abrite et
entretient une communauté
interdépendantes qui s'alimentent des
produits chimiques contenus dans l'eau
et qui puise son énergie dans la chaleur
volcanique la colonisation d'une surface
recouverte de cendres volcaniques est
particulièrement difficile
des années après son irruption le mont
sainte hélène reste une terre désertique
sur anac krakatoa dont l'existence
remonte à une soixantaine d'années le
processus de colonisation est cependant
en marche
non seulement il n'existe de plantes
géantes comme seule fille une canne à
sucre sauvage mais également des armes
et si vous voulez voir le résultat d'un
siècle de colonisation par les plantes
regardez cette partie plus ancienne de
krakatoa nous savons grâce à des
rapports effectués il ya une centaine
d'années qu'à l'époque on ne trouvait
ici qu'une couche de cendre stérile de
plusieurs mètres d'épaisseur
en l'espace de trois ans 34 espèces de
plantes sont réapparus
dix ans plus tard ce nombre avait doublé
et est apparue entre temps une centaine
de races d'oiseaux et d'insectes
certaines graines étaient parvenus en
flottant de l'île de java à 32 km 10 et
le mouvement se poursuit certaines
autres graines ont sans doute été
apportée par des oiseaux soit sur leurs
pattes soit dans leur estomac il ya
maintenant sur l'île plusieurs centaines
d'espèces de plans les ventes ont enfin
mais d'innombrables insectes volants
dont les descendants forme maintenant
une vaste population permanente qui
assurent la pollinisation des fleurs
s'alimentant de leurs fruits de leurs
feuilles se nourrissant aussi les uns
les autres
akhatova et les nombreuses autres
volcans en éruption qui s'échelonnent
entre java sumatra et les autres îles de
la région indonésienne se situe sur la
ligne de faille de la croûte terrestre
ou le plateau de basalte formant le fond
de l'océan indien rencontre la partie
partiellement submergée du continent
asiatique
cette jonction existait déjà il y à 65
millions d'années lorsque la ddt était
une île isolée au milieu de cet océan
à ce moment les continents se sont
déplacés et l'inde s'est rapproché de
l'asie les sédiments qui les séparaient
se sont chevauchés par dessus la
jonction formant une immense chaîne de
montagnes l'himalaya
aussi ces grands pics de grès et de
calcaire qui l'ignorent à quelques 8000
mètres ne sont pas seulement les plus
hauts du monde mais également parmi les
plus récents par ailleurs le processus
pour fui l'inde continue son déplacement
vers le nord un rythme estimé à 5 cm par
an elles se passent ainsi toujours plus
fortement contre la masse continentale
de l'asie et même si c'est de manière
affinités himal l'himalaya continue de
grandir
voilà pourquoi cette ammonites créatures
marines se retrouvent ici à 3200 mètres
d'altitude dans l'himalaya
voilà aussi pourquoi la rivière reagan
date a réussi à se tracer un chemin si
parfait à travers la plus haute chaîne
montagneuse du monde elle coulait vers
le sud
venant de l'ancien plateau du tibet bien
avant que l'énorme masse de l'inde
n'entrent en contact avec l'asie pendant
que les sédiments entre ces deux masses
terrestres s'élevait s'entasser pendant
des millions d'années
la rivière a maintenu son cours
descendant à travers la roche au fur et
à mesure que celle-ci s'élevait
aujourd'hui elle continue de couler vers
le sud jusqu'au plein de l'ade à travers
les gorges les plus profondes du monde
les animaux et les plantes ont réussi à
s'adapter à vivre même près des sommets
dans un environnement qui avec celui des
pôles est certainement le plus
inhospitaliers qui soit